i think that we're so afraid
that we're going to raise you know
serial killers or i don't know what way
we think we're going to raise
um that we're constantly controlling our
kids and yelling at them and that's
actually what's going to send them
torpedoing on the wrong path
so i think the more we relax
and let go of our
desire to control and micromanage our
children's destiny
and the more we just enjoy them build a
connection
express our love be in the present and
declutter our own life and
reorganize our own levels of stress
our children
for the most part are going to be
quite okay
and stop wanting perfect children stop
wanting extraordinary children allow
yourself to accept
their fallibilities their flaws their
limitations and their ordinariness
people worry too much
because we are trying to be
extraordinary
because i believe in
before anything else to have less stress
and high expectations cause high stress
and that is never a good thing never
ever ever is it a good thing even with a
high functioning super achiever kit it's
not a good thing so take away the stress
take away the high expectations and the
intensity
and a simpler life will lead to a more
competent more empowered more secure
child
that was dr shafali saberi shefali is a
clinical psychologist a public speaker
and a new york times best-selling author
including her two landmark books the
conscious parent and the awakened family
which are some of my favorite parenting
books she's an expert in family dynamics
and personal development teaching
courses around the globe and i can
almost guarantee her insights will blow
you away bringing to light thought
processes that we often don't consider
because of all the layers of experiences
we've had growing up in our own life and
cultural norms this conversation was
completely enlightening for me providing
reminders that are so easy to forget
when the ego gets in the way and life
gets busy i would love to hear your
biggest takeaways from this episode so
please respond in the comments or write
a review now let's get into this episode
i hope you enjoy it welcome back to the
podcast everyone i am so excited for
today's guest dr shifali saberi thank
you so much for being here oh it's an
honor i'm excited
i have read both of your books the
conscious parent and the awakened family
and they were truly pivotal pivotal in
my parenting journey and i just feel so
thankful that i get to sit face to face
with you and ask those burning questions
because it's an ever evolving journey
right
sure i'm excited shoot away so my first
question is
something that i think will help lay the
groundwork for the entire episode and i
was wanting to answer what is the true
role of the parent
the true role of the parent is to
heal themselves
so that they can guide their children's
essence their true selves
into existence into flight
and into manifestation
so that is the real true role of the
parent
and how can we as parents become more
joyful and less stressful and less
burned out in our
pursuit to be that way for our kids
yeah i mean it's really a very deep
question because
that question
requires that the parent have awareness
they structure their own life according
to
principles that are more aligned that
are not chaotic you know most of us
today are robotically habituated to
living these very
you know obsessively manic lives
and
we take our children to 10 000
activities a day
and
we you know move them from one thing to
the next not realizing
that we are taking them
down this labyrinth of complete mania
and then we're stressed out then no one
is happy then we are in conflict
and we're wondering why
why this is so well it is so because we
have cluttered our lives with so much
excessive
madness
because of this culture this pressure
that we feel to achieve and to
be magnificent that is all quite
unnecessary
so how do we change that right well we
have to first become aware
that this is even happening to us what
if it's something beyond our awareness
then we're not even going to get off the
conveyor belts so we have to realize
that we are on this roller coaster
and then make conscious choices like i'm
sure you've made a conscious choice
living where you are i'm sure your pace
of life is has got to be slower than
here on the mainland
and so how did you make that choice
right you made it because you saw
something was dysfunctional and you
committed to a different way of
existence
absolutely that was one of the main
reasons that we moved here is because i
wanted to slow down i wanted to raise my
kids barefoot
in nature and
just slow life down help them to just
you know provide for them ways to
experience childhood at its fullest in a
way that's not so stressful so yeah when
you say it like that that is really one
of the reasons why we moved here
exactly so people have to make that you
know have have that awareness
realize that it's toxic and then make a
new choice right so it's a very deep
question it sounds like an easy question
one two three but it's not it requires a
tremendous level of
awareness and desire to change and
desire to be different
and does that kind of change based on
each child's personality as well like
some kids might thrive more in more
activities and maybe others not as much
is that do you think that's something to
consider
absolutely you know we we absolutely
have to contour
our approach and our style to our kids
you know temperament and we have to
align them together
so it it changes with every single kid
totally
i think a lot of parents want like quick
tips and tricks on how to like get their
child to listen
right and then we find ourselves in this
pattern of like how do i how do i just
get the get life to just be calmer and
smoother when a lot of times it can be
just like a more holistic approach to
slowing life down a little bit as as
much as we can while also also fostering
like the activities and types of things
that they're really excited about
yes exactly so you know it's hard when
you have a lot of kids and that's the
balancing act and you have to kind of
nurture each one's temperament and match
uh the external with the internal
right
and i know a lot of what you talk about
in your books is like bringing it back
to the parent and like what can i change
to be my best most evolved self to
help create a peaceful family life what
do you have to say for those who are
really feel like they're doing their
very best to present their best selves
but like their child still is just
constantly has an attitude or won't
listen and they're like what do i do
how do i naturally decrease conflict and
increase cooperation without trying to
like control our child
yeah and that's why this work is so
incredibly you know difficult because it
is a balancing act it's a tightrope
you know you want them to get out of bed
and go to school and
do some chores and do some activities
but you don't want to control them
but what if they're not listening and
you know so you have to
work with it you know and
and remember some core principles which
are
you don't want to shame them you don't
want to coerce them you want to be as
creative as possible to
find their sweet spot
and create a life with them not for them
and you don't project your own
fantasies and desires onto your kids you
really
you know curate a new kind of life that
that is consciously attuned to their
needs
and you let go of the old ways of
parenting where you control them where
you dominated them where you punish them
and you find a new way i mean that's
what i teach in conscious parenting is a
whole new way of parenting
right and the creative aspect i think is
so key and you really have to get inside
yourself and your brain and before
reacting to a situation like reflect
what would be the best response where
it's so easy to want to just quickly
react because we're all busy and we're
like just wanting our children to listen
especially when it's important
and
i've found that when i take those
creative approaches from reading books
like yours like things that you would
never even consider for an example i
read somewhere if your child doesn't
want to listen to hold your hand across
the street instead of just shaming them
and making it this really fearful thing
making it a game um like holding hands
um like oh there's alligators in the
street and will you hold my hand so i'm
not scared let's pretend the cars are
alligators and just creative ways like
that and i find kids instead of coming
right because we as adults we've lost
our imagination
and we just want to do a top-down
hierarchical
you know command and follow me approach
and that's not the way like you said be
playful and kids will love it
kids love to brush their teeth if you
make it playful and make it fun you know
make them brush your teeth and you'll
brush their teeth and brush the doll's
teeth and brush the you know the the
teddy bears teeth and when you do it
like that then they have fun with it but
we have lost that imagination and that
playful spontaneity and we just do this
like do this and then do that and we
make life so
so much of a drudge for our kids and
then we wonder why they shut down and
why they push back well they do that
because we're not meeting them where
they are at we're asking them to come to
us where we are at and that's always
going to be met with resistance because
children live in the world of fun and
spontaneity not orders and timetables
and schedules like we do
yeah
i i sometimes try to put myself in their
shoes and realize like whoa if i had
these two big adults like speaking into
me speaking to me this way all the time
telling me what to do
that would not feel good and i would
probably have an attitude as well
yes good so this
capacity to put ourselves in their shoes
means
seeing the world a little bit from their
eyes they are small
we
we overpower them in size and voice and
dominance
we are in control of everything how does
it feel to be
you know powerless
and when you can understand that they
like all of us want to feel in control
autonomous powerful
then we will give them that find
opportunities where they feel competent
where they feel like they are our
leaders imagine being pushed around like
we want to push our children around
imagine
a world where you make no rules where
you have no voice
eventually that
child or that being is going to lash out
in volcanic anger so the more you can
put yourself in your kid's shoes and and
go what are some ways i can give my kid
power i can give my my kid control they
can choose what color
plate we're going to eat on they're
going to they're going to choose whether
they sit on this chair or that chair
the more choices we give them
we may feel like we're letting them run
the roost but what we're really doing is
building their their inner sense of
empowerment which is so critical
that's so true because i've found in my
own personal life the more power that i
give to my children the more confident
they become and the more kind they
become because they feel respected by us
because we're not treating them like
these like unimportant unable to do
anything for themselves beings
absolutely and let me tell you
when you raise kids like this it can be
a little bit of a pain and a payback
because then they'll talk back to you
they'll have an attitude about
everything they have an opinion but
guess what that's the kind of adult you
want to raise you want to raise an adult
who has a brain who can talk back you
know we we parents hate the talk back
but when you really step back and think
about it what that means is that we want
a puppet
every human being talks back right you
and i are talking back i'm talking back
at you
so if talking back doesn't mean
disrespect it means having an opinion
having something to say
having a vantage and allowing oneself to
express it and this is what our kids
need to do
but we parents don't want them to do it
with us we just want them to do it out
in their life but how are they going to
learn it if they don't do it with us
absolutely one of my children in
particular is very good at discourse and
so if he doesn't like
the rules that we've set in place or he
doesn't think it's fair or he thinks we
should do something different he will
respond with his reasons and part of
that i think
is because we've taught him like hey if
you don't like what we have to say
tell us why you don't like it try to
change our mind with your words calmly
and respectfully and i might change my
mind because sometimes
sometimes he makes amazing points and
i'm like oh i really shouldn't have this
rule that doesn't make sense and if he's
very good at explaining something
respectfully to me then then i do change
my mind and that teaches them to be
respectful to to navigate life that way
with other people i think to know how to
handle that kind of conversation
yes so these are beautiful skills
of dialogue negotiation
achieving compromise sharing one's
thoughts because this gives them power
wow i can use my intelligence to change
the mind of an adult that's a real power
that we can give our kids so that they
know they're not afraid of adults they
can talk with teachers and with bus
drivers and with
you know with adults in the library we
should not
create this sort of
us versus them approach that often we do
with this hierarchical dominating kind
of parenting
so for a specific example about when a
child who's like a little bit older
maybe seven ten seven eight nine ten and
if they're not responding in a way
that's calm and collected and respectful
like we're trying to teach them how do
you respond to a situation like that
when it when like a creative approach
for like a three or four year old
wouldn't really work
so you know you you just you just try
and say hey
you know i i noticed that you're talking
to me with this attitude and i'm just
asking you a question and you know as
long as you can keep the humor and
reflect back
and
not react not react in a negative way
um i don't i think that it's a learning
curve some kids are more defiant
and they kind of test you more and some
kids are more compliant and they
withdraw and they acquiesce more so
again depending on the kind of kid you
have
you take it in your stride and you just
be the mirror you know and keep
reflecting back and
you can leave the room you know after
they're seven or eight you can say hey
i don't appreciate the way you're
speaking with me so why don't you chill
and when you when you're chill we'll
talk about it
versus
fu2 you know or versus
uh leave leave the room and we're
raising our voice right
so one of the things that's helpful and
i remind parents all the time is
if you expect
expect your kid to defy you and you
expect them to test you then when they
do
you won't see it as a sign of disrespect
you'll understand that it's part of the
developmental curve
most kids will defy
and test
and then most kids will comply and
withdraw so you have to know what kind
of kid you have
and don't be surprised when it happens
be ready for it and be prepared for it
right and is there any specific tools
it's not you've already explained really
well
about that but
for children who are especially
high-spirited
how can we
you know
navigate and help children to be
respectful and listen to the home
without like breaking their spirit
well first stop chasing respect you know
what is respect
each person will say
respect is something else
you know so if the kid curses you once
in a while is that terrible like
i mean i think we become so puritanical
and rigid
and if we understand the basic concept
of childhood
which is they are learning
they're going to test
they're going to try
they're going to experiment
then we won't be so up in arms
and
we parents are very righteous sometimes
and we pretty much call everything we
don't like disrespect
and we need to just tone it down a bit
you know
it's not personal everything is not
about us it's not that the kid is being
disrespectful the kid is just going
through their own experience they're
trying to learn and grow and evolve
um
you know there was a phase where my
daughter was extremely quote-unquote
disrespectful
and talking to me like i was her friend
and i said to her you know i'm not your
friend
i'm not your friend i'm your mother and
she i mean just as recently as a few
months ago said but you are my friend
mom
and i was well i don't appreciate the
way you talk to me and she was like mom
come on i talk to you like i talk to my
friends
and
it was really hard for my ego
to accept that but when i understood
where she was coming from i realized
it's not as personal as i'm making it
you know but but she was using like the
f like f bombs all over the place and i
was like can you not talk like this in
front of me and she's like why
i'm like because i'm not your friend and
she's like no but you are and that and
then the dollar got so silly where i'm
insisting
that i'm not her friend which is not
what i want to do
so again it's not so clear-cut and if
you understand what's going on inside
your kid and where they're coming from
like now when she drops f-bombs around
me she's 19 almost i don't take it
personally because i know where she's
coming from it's actually a compliment
because she thinks i'm so easy going and
i'm just like one of her buddies she's
not seeing me as separate but i want her
to see me on this hierarchical pedestal
so my ego is getting bruised you see but
if we can just relax first understand
that it may not be what we think it may
have nothing to do with us it may not
have anything to do with respect and
then number four
get below the words and understand what
is your child trying to communicate
maybe they're in trouble maybe they had
a rough day at school maybe they were
being bullied or maybe like my daughter
she thinks there's nothing wrong because
she treats me like her friend so assess
each situation don't just jump into this
cultural roboticism that oh that is
disrespect because culture says it's
disrespect
yeah i think that what you said there
takes a lot of the pressure off and a
lot of the fear away like it lets the
let's go with the fear because a lot of
our like a lot of things that you say in
your talks and your books is about how
so much of what how we react to our
children is fear-based
and i think part of it is like fear that
our child won't grow up to be a
respectful person to other people
in the real world but when you take that
pressure off and realize hey they're
just children learning and growing and
trying to figure things out it might
help us not to be so reactionary when
our children aren't quote unquote being
disrespectful you know
right i mean i think that we're so
afraid
that we're going to raise you know
serial killers or i don't know what way
we think we're going to raise
um that we're constantly controlling our
kids and yelling at them and that's
actually what's going to send them
torpedoing on the wrong path
so i think the more we relax
and let go of our
desire to control and micromanage our
children's destiny and the more we just
enjoy them build a connection
express our love be in the present and
declutter our own life and
reorganize our own levels of stress
our children i for the most part are
going to be
quite okay
and stop wanting perfect children stop
wanting extraordinary children allow
yourself to accept
their fallibilities their flaws their
limitations and their ordinariness
hmm
that's so beautifully said
okay i have another question for you
when it comes to things like natural
consequences because do you feel like
there are certain things that have
boundaries right and
how where's that it's such a fine line
sometimes
and are there any times where
something maybe wouldn't have a natural
consequence but kind of needs direction
like if a child is being like we've
talked about earlier about like a high
spirit child who does have like a like
maybe an attitude or something and is
there ever a time for consequences or
natural consequences in your eyes
of course i mean natural consequences
are happening all the time
right so if a kid is hitting their
brother
we could tell the brother well don't
play with him so then the kid loses
the
the play or the companionship of that
brother or if the kid is being rude to
you you can say hey i'm not engaging
anymore and you leave the room so now
the kid has to deal with an empty room
so natural consequences are built into
life and
what you're talking about is an enforced
boundary
and of course there's sometimes we need
to have enforced boundaries for example
if your kid you know wants to buy a
sixteen hundred dollar pair of shoes
you're not gonna allow a kid to i hope
wear sixteen hundred dollar pair of
shoes ever
and so you're gonna say no you can have
a sixty dollar pair of shoes maybe you
know so we we're always using common
sense
according to our own values you know
maybe we don't keep cookies and ice
cream and doughnuts in our house because
we know
that our kids don't have boundaries so
that's an enforced boundary right
so again if the parent is kind of
you know relatively intelligent common
sense and does their own inner healing
we're not going to it's it's really hard
to really really
[ __ ] things up you know we're all gonna
mess it up but to really mess it up
you need to be like some level of psycho
you know so don't people worry too much
because we are trying to be
extraordinary and if we let go of that
rigid control and just say hey we're
gonna have a kid that's just you know a
regular kid good enough and i'm okay
with it then that takes all the pressure
off and we begin to enjoy our children
just in the ordinary moment of it
without
trying to create this this idea of
perfection it's this idea of perfection
that creates the stress and that you
know
sends us
into this chaos when the shoulds are not
being met
right and when you said about taking the
stress off and also organizing your own
life you said that earlier that will
help us to respond better to our
children which is incredible
exactly exactly so you instead of
looking at them as a reflection of you
or looking at them as a project to be
created or completed or looking at them
as somebody to be fixed and solved and
managed and you know corrected right
away you relax and just go it's a kid
who's learning and it's going to take
millions of moments to build their
muscles it's not going to happen today
you know i still i'm telling my 19 year
old can you say thank you can you please
pick up your plate you know it's just
life till they grow up and then when
they have to do it for themselves they
will but you have to have that trust
that they will
the way you explain it is so beautiful
and it reminds me of my own childhood
that when i would go to
other people's families houses and i
would see the way that their parents
interacted with each other you really as
a child feel the stress or lowered or
lack of stress depending on which
family's house that you're at and it
really does help create a more peaceful
dynamic when you explain it that way
when i'm at a friend's house growing up
and the parents are super calm relaxed
loving you just feel this peace
as opposed to being at a house where
there's high strung and all these like
rules that just seem a little
unnecessary so yeah that's just a really
really great way to explain that
yeah and you asked you said something
about healing our inner self so that we
can take care of our children better how
do
people help heal their inner child
based on if they had childhood
experiences where they felt were
damaging from their own parents
yeah i mean they they take those
wounds really seriously and you know go
to a coach go to a therapist take
courses i do tons of courses for parents
to become better parents
because we have to take these wounds
seriously we cannot
allow our wounds to lay bare and
bleeding
because they will
subsume our children's psyche they will
bleed over onto our children's psyche
yeah i think we have to take the power
back and realize that we are in control
of our healing and that we don't have to
just let it take over us and say that
this is just who i am because of my
experience and my childhood we can heal
by taking action and
yeah everyone i recommend go check out
your courses you have so many beautiful
courses on your site so can we shift the
conversation a little bit to
like sibling relationships how can
parents
best foster sibling relationships
well you know by
not again interfering too much
and micromanaging that relationship and
handling their own issues around
conflict
the main
issue that comes up for parents with
siblings is their inability to tolerate
conflict so if you are a parent who
wants happy happy happy children all the
time then you should not have had more
than one child you should just not have
had children
because it's just not possible so the
minute you have more than one kid they
are going to fight they're going to
annoy each other they're going to attack
each other
and you as a parent needs to learn to
tolerate that
without exaggerating and catastrophizing
the problem
what about if one of them is
consistently picking on the other
whereas the other one isn't really
picking on the other one back
yeah it's really really difficult and
you have to empower the picked on child
to use their words to speak up to leave
the room empower that child not to be
bullied
versus just focusing on the
quote-unquote bullying bully child the
one who's the bully to tone down their
bullying you know and empathize with the
bully what's going on you know if the
kid is a bully you know what i mean but
yeah empathize with them what's going on
with you
spend more time with that kid it's more
likely the older kid who's feeling like
this younger one has come and taken his
place on the on the throne
so
spend more time with that older kid
empower the older kid that they don't
have to hate their younger sibling
that they don't have to attack them that
they have mom's attention
and don't play favorites you know i mean
those are the standard protocol
yes oh my gosh that's such good advice
and i think about how if one of my
children is getting picked on by the
other and let's say the the one who's
picking on the child is calling them a
baby you're a baby and i'll tell my
younger child like you don't have to let
that bother you you know that by him
calling you that that doesn't mean that
you are that and if it doesn't bother
you then he'll likely stop calling you
that
right right right it's hard
but um yeah i think the minute you make
one of them a bad guy
that bad guy will get more angry and act
out more so resist the temptation
to be referee
resist the temptation to fix it too fast
and resist the temptation to create a
bad guy
um that's such good advice and i think
growing up that was that was definitely
an experience of mine where i would pick
on my younger sister and every time my
sister would scream my parents would
come running and be like ellen what did
you do
you know so then my sister started
wanting to scream more and more every
time i did something and it was like
this weird thing that just made
everything imbalanced
see so it's it's not fair to either
sibling
when one is is you know customarily the
bad guy
because then the other one becomes a
tattletale and the other like your
sister did and she becomes like that's
not her highest self either
so
parents need to have this attitude
that
both will fall into trouble
both will have to deal with the
consequences both will face the same
music
so that they realize that there's no
payoff here
yes totally
and not putting so much emphasis on
either one as being the issue but more
just like exactly stepping back my mom
actually used to say when we were
fighting to just go work it out in your
in our rooms instead of her trying to
delegate it she'd be like go to your
room to work it out together and that
was nice for us to be like oh my mom
isn't going to just come in and fix it
all
you see you see the best attitude for
parents to have is
you guys chose to play together
and you guys need to fix it and figure
it out especially if they're past five
years old you know
and the more you don't give attention
and don't stroke it and don't take it as
a sensational
life event and show complete utter
boredom by them they will not get a hit
you see
and they won't get the attention that
they're seeking and they'll eventually
move away because it's not exciting mom
is not getting excited
that's so true when i find myself
getting excited and getting anxious or
upset at what they're doing it does not
make it better it makes them want to do
it more
100 because they're getting attention
right i know oh that's such a good
reminder thank you
so something i want to talk about is how
you mention a lot the importance of not
putting our projected desires onto our
children and i think that's one of the
most incredible information that you've
that you've helped parents realize so
can you explain why that's so important
and how we as parents can teach
ourselves to let go of our ego and our
agendas
right well it's not easy to let it go
but the first step is to become aware
that a lot of our shoulds
our expectations are not coming from the
inherent
uh
child
and their essence and their desires but
they're coming from our fantasies and
then the second part of this is to
really realize
when we are pushing an agenda for our
ego
or when are we pushing for an agenda
because it's truly beneficial for the
child
right the difference between telling a
child they need to wear a pretty frock
with bows and pretty blue shoes
versus telling a kid hey you haven't had
a shower for 24 hours now let's go wash
up
the first one is purely for your ego the
second one is life sustaining and it is
truly for their benefit that they have a
shower now so do you see the difference
so there are very few things that are
truly for their benefit and once we
realize that most of the things we push
for fight for argue about get stressed
about are mostly coming from our ego
we will begin to shed that and life will
become simpler better more enjoyable
more more empowered
um
yeah
and does that go for things as they get
older as well i imagine like what you
want for their life and what you think
will be best for their life
yeah we don't know what we what we want
for them we shouldn't know what we want
for them and we don't know what's best
for them and when i say this to parents
they really revolt they're like i know
what's best no you don't you don't even
know what's best for you and what's best
for you now may not be best for you in
two days
so how can you predict what's best for
your kid down the line all you know is
the kid right now
you right now and the present moment and
just keep it here now of course
you know because we live in this world
they should graduate okay
but we take it moment by moment how they
graduate when they graduate which school
they graduate from is always going to be
a moving target
so we can't really focus on too many
details all we can do is focus on the
present moment and go step by step and
remove the delusion
that we know what's best because we
don't know what's best about anybody's
life including our own
and can you explain a little bit about
projecting our agendas when it comes to
things like religion and certain values
as well on our children
yeah well parents won't like to hear
that but
when we when we enforce our religious
beliefs on our children we are
you know projecting and parents don't
want to see that because they don't see
their
religious beliefs as
as
constructions
they see their religious beliefs as
divinely ordained
so
when people believe in those things it's
really hard to speak to that
and they're going to feel like they're
bad parents if they don't give their
children that same belief system but
you know
it is
they you know it takes a highly evolved
parent to understand
that their religious beliefs are
constructed by man
something that they have unconsciously
robotically followed
and that they have a choice
most parents don't see a choice in that
they think that it is divinely ordained
and if they don't do it they will go to
hell
so i understand why parents feel the
pressure
to project the their religious beliefs
onto their children
yeah i kind of feel like even if you
really really believe in what you do in
order to
to help raise your children to be well
adjusted and not resent you for
protecting projecting your own
beliefs on them i i found it helpful to
just say like hey this is what i believe
but like as you get older and learn more
you're going to have to come to the
conclusions of what you believe
yeah but you're really open and flexible
most parents are rigid and dogmatic and
they kind of brainwash their kids at an
early age
so the ideal way is to do you know if
you are going to have religious beliefs
leave it open allow children to know
they have the freedom to choose
and this is not set in stone nor is it
divinely ordained but if you're going to
have you know it's hard it's like being
a little pregnant you can't be a little
pregnant you know so if you have a
religious belief that you know
there's a heaven in hell and there's a
god up in the sky
how do you tell the kid but you believe
what you want
you know
i believe that we are we are you know
that there's a man up all god up there
who knows everything and sees us doing
everything but you believe what you want
you understand it's it's hard it's it
seems inconsistent and it could be very
confusing for the kid to go huh what
you know you believe in an all supreme
being but you're telling me who is in
charge of my destiny but you're like
believe what you want
right it doesn't work together that's
why we have to be aligned
but i do think it's helpful too to
remind parents like hey you could
potentially be pushing your child away
further by trying to push your
perspectives on your child grow all
growing up and saying like
things like you can't question anything
else or you can question something else
but you have to come back to this answer
and not realizing that when as they grow
up into an adult they're more likely or
a lot of times might want to push that
away further simply because of this
dogmatic
way of thinking that you put on to your
child so i think that's a worthy
discussion
for sure but yeah
it's definitely layered it's definitely
layered
yes
um so can do you have any advice for
handling
anger and to be patient um in times of
high stress with parenting
you know
it's hard to handle anger in the moment
of anger you have to
make a decision of how you're living
your life it's a big big answer it's not
like oh how to handle anger one two
three in the moment
it's
why
you know why are we getting angry in the
first place
we how can we get angry with with beings
who don't know how to be different they
truly don't know how to be different so
anger is a moot point it's our own
resistance
to reality
that is making us angry if we flowed
with our children
accepted them for who it is they are
and understood that their brain has not
even developed they have huge gaps and
so they're going to forget they're going
to mess up they're going to be rude
they're going to not use their words
they're going to yell and scream if we
understand that their brains are not
developed then we'll understand that
getting angry is completely silly it's
like getting angry with the weather
you know it says you don't get angry
with the weather you know and in the
same way our children are like the
weather they're going to change
constantly so getting angry with them is
just our own inability to understand
reality as it is
yeah and i think a lot of it has to do
with fear too because we have this idea
in our head that maybe everyone else has
it figured out and everyone else's
family is doing well and they're all
respectful because when you see it on
the surface maybe on social media or in
real life at the store it seems like
maybe your kids are the only ones that
are acting out and so it creates this
anxiety and you're more likely to act
out of fear and respond in anger but the
way that you explain it is so
relatable and it helps people to realize
like hey everybody's going through it
this is
childhood this is life
and that's a really good reminder to
just relax because when you take the
fear away it's easier to respond calmly
yes exactly exactly
and how should we help children manage
their feelings and their anger
well first we
you know hold space for them give them
give them the room to explore it without
suppressing them or labeling it as bad
and then when they're able and if
they're able to talk about it oh you
were really angry you angry because you
were really tired or you angry because
somebody got angry with you and now
you're dumping it on me you know so i
began telling my daughter when she was
young oh you know sam got angry with you
and now you're angry with me you know do
you see that and or you're really ups
you know upset about something that
happened at school but you're dumping on
me
and i was like hey don't dump on me i
has to make a joke out of it but to kind
of show them how it works you know and
try not to take it personally and
validate them like i understand you're
angry or i see that you're upset or i'm
sorry mommy upset you take
accountability for your role in it don't
be afraid to
you know own it and if they're upset
with you it's okay it's good that
they're expressing it
and you know suppressed anger is the
worst it comes out against the self
it comes out in self-harming and we
don't want that
yeah
100 it reminds me of a time recently
when i picked up my child
he's older than an age where like you
should be picking them up but i just
picked him up just impulsively because
he was in a spot that was like unsafe or
gonna cause or gonna cause like a big
mess on my counter so i picked him up
impulsively and put him down and he
started screaming at me and i had to own
that and be like as much as he didn't
have to scream like that and over like
just make it this huge deal i also
probably should have just told him with
my words like hey i need you to get down
instead of just picking him up and
knowing that about each child the
differences and what upsets them more
because we're all individuals that he
doesn't like to be moved and picked up
and forced into certain places that
that's gonna cause some resistance so by
me just apologizing and hey oh okay i'm
sorry i understand that that really
upset you and putting words to their
feelings instead of saying like you
shouldn't you should scream like that i
can't believe that you're gonna
overreact right
right right because they don't like to
be moved around and shoved around like
furniture yeah so you could say
something oh mommy's so silly silly
mommy
sorry sweetheart right i mean why not i
mean because we we forget
that they are sovereign beings and we
treat them like furniture really
yeah and it helps them to feel so much
better when we just put words to their
feelings because as an adult it's the
same way if if you're trying to express
sadness or upset being upset about
something and then your partner's like
ugh get over it type of thing like it
doesn't help you feel better what helps
me move through it is if my partner's
gonna say oh you're really upset by this
i understand why you feel that way and i
think it's easy for us as parents to
forget that children need that too
yes yes yes so a lot of my audience
wanted me to ask you what your thoughts
are on social media and screen time for
kids
and tv
well we want to limit it to the last
possible moment in time
i mean i know your friends in maui must
be more out in nature and that's what
you want your kids to do
i regret the day that i gave my daughter
a phone i didn't know i was giving her a
drug
and you know my generation of parents
can really plead ignorance because we
didn't know we really didn't know we
were so excited when the iphone came out
we had no idea but younger parents need
to know it is crack cocaine heroin all
rolled into one do not give your kid a
portable device
until the last possible moment in
adolescence when they are literally
going to
leave the house you can give it to them
like try your best
to keep them off-screen still their
teens minimum
right and then you want to try a little
longer no screens in their room i mean i
i'm a bit hard about it because i've
seen the negative effects i can't stand
it it hurts my heart
and don't use it as a nanny don't use it
as a
candy you know tvs are better you know
i'm like let's go back to the good old
tv
you know tv was much better than these
portable devices because this way they
carry it on their bodies and it becomes
an extension so if you have young kids
learn from the ones of us who have
messed up our kids by giving up giving
them the screens and do not allow the
screens next to your kids they are
not equipped to handle it
there they don't need it it's not
necessary
yeah
board to death rather than get a screen
and do you mean specifically like having
their own phone and social media or do
you also mean like family movies
no of course family yeah
the tv is much better
because you can take away the remote
they can't carry the tv with them i'm
talking about portable devices their own
phone screens in their pocket
no no no no no especially if your kids
are young there's there's no need for
them we didn't grow up like that so
there's no need for them to grow up like
that i am so on the same page i find it
i find social media addicting as an
adult let alone a young child with a
developing brain and so i'm trying to
get all my friends to be like can we all
just agree that none of our kids get
smartphones until they're 18. like can
we just all be on board with that so
that none of the kids are like well they
have it and they have it because they
don't understand how how addicting it is
and also damaging to their psyche with
all of the face filters and everything
on social media all the comparison game
i can't even imagine if i went through
that in high school
yes it is it is toxic beyond toxic and
damaging yes and when it comes to screen
time like family movies that we were
talking about what if a child like wants
to watch a lot of tv do you have what
are your thoughts on just like
boundaries for like
you know it's okay if they're watching
cartoons and but of course you don't
want them sitting there for two or three
hours you know you want 30 minutes here
30 minutes there
while you're cooking dinner while you're
making something while you're handling a
call
you know they're not going to be damaged
with cartoons once in a while you know
even two 30-minute sessions a day is not
going to hurt them it's the addictive
nature of social media that is the new
toxin yes i completely agree we kind of
have like a two
tuesdays and saturdays is when they
watch cartoons in the morning so they
have this real structure about it and
they know when it's coming and they're
not going to beg for it every day
because they know they just wait till
tuesdays and saturdays so they get to do
that and then we do like family movies a
couple times a week and that's that
feels good for us
excellent
so i just have a few more questions for
you
some of my audience wanted me to ask you
do you feel it's okay in your eyes for
two parents to
um have different approaches to
parenting and kind of respond to their
children differently
well ideally we want to be one but it
never really
often never happens so
so you do the best you can you know and
mishmush it and you know you're very
lucky if you both think the same
it's amazing if you both think the same
and that's rare
most of the times one is going to be
more permissive one is going to be more
conscious
one is going to be less so
you're going to you know if it is that
way you just work with what you got
and do the what you can do the best you
can
and minimize the effects of the
traditional control hierarchical
dogmatic rigid parenting you want to be
more relaxed you want to be more
conscious you want to be more easy going
those kinds of parents raise happier
kids
and that totally reminds me of like an
impulse that i might have sometimes so
want to say no to something but if i
stop for a moment before replying it'll
help me think wait do i need to say no
to this something like my little
three-year-old girl wanting to play with
this lip gloss she found in my in my bag
and i know it's gonna cause a mess and i
know she's gonna get it all over her
arms and her face but she wants to use
the lip gloss and so instead of saying
no just saying yes like go ahead and use
it and in my head i'm like we'll clean
her up in like 15 minutes
right right i always tell parents to try
and find the no before you try and find
the yes inside the no try and find the
yes before you say no try and find the
way to change the note to a yes so even
if you're saying no
you're actually saying yes something
like
what a great idea to watch that movie
but oh no we can't watch it today but
can we watch it tomorrow you see
like you're honoring the desire but and
you're not just shooting them down
you're finding a way to affirm their
their life desire
and understanding that they have desires
just like you but you're not
capitulating to it and indulging it but
you're also not just shooting it down
because it's such a dumb idea you know
totally that's such a good reminder
um
i have two more questions what is the
most common mistakes parents make
in parenting
the most common mistake i think is that
they take it personally
they think it's against them for them to
them everything is about them them them
them and
as long as they come like that they're
going to mess it up and they're going to
lose
connection and i think another common
mistake is that they believe
that correction is as important as
connection and it isn't connection comes
before correction all this stuff earns
that
that's so important because when we
connect with our child we're more likely
to have an easier relationship where we
won't need to correct as much
yes
it's so true because you could have days
where you're like why is everything off
why is there so much attitude why is
nothing vibing and then when you just
bring that connection together the next
day is like the most peaceful day ever
and it really shows how important
connection is
yes yes yes
okay so i really i wanted to ask you
this that i've never heard you speak on
maybe maybe you said it before but i
just have missed it but what was your
childhood like and how has that
influenced who you've become today and
what you're passionate about
yeah so i mean that's also very complex
question but just simply put i was
raised
with
almost very low expectations and what
that means is i was raised
with no stress you know very very
relatively little stress so i laugh with
my parents i go you guys didn't expect
much of me
but thank goodness because i was allowed
to find my own inner expectation and i
didn't feel stressed
i didn't feel pushed i felt like i had
to push like can i please take that
class can i please do more can i please
study more
they i don't know what they they thought
i would turn out to be but
and part of it i think was because they
just
saw that i was naturally hardworking i
don't know but i just have raised my
daughter in the same way because i
believe in
before anything else to have less stress
and high expectations cause high stress
and that is never a good thing never
ever ever is it a good thing even with a
high functioning super achiever kid it's
not a good thing so take away the stress
take away the high expectations and the
intensity
and a simpler life will lead to a more
competent more empowered more secure
child hmm
yeah that reminds me a little bit of my
own childhood how my parents were never
suspicious of me they were never
thinking i was breaking rules or going
behind their back and as a result like
they just trusted me a lot and i and so
because i felt trusted i didn't i didn't
feel a need to lash out or to hide
things because i knew that if i did mess
up like they were always there with a
calm demeanor and i don't have a single
memory of my parents yelling at me
so yeah i think that you're onto
something there completely
i love it lucky you yeah
well wow this was such a great
conversation thank you so much for all
of your insight i really appreciate
everything that you have to share and
put out into the world
and i definitely recommend everyone
listening or watching watching this to
read both of her books the conscious
parent and the awakened family they're
really really inspiring and pivotal and
i found them very influential in my own
parenting journey so thank you so much
wonderful thank you for having me
continue the great work
bye bye
[Music]
you